- I actually, okay, I'm a fan.
Are you guys a fan of Kelly?
Obviously, I'm a big fan.
- Oh, you (laughs).
- I will go--
(audience applauds)
I will go on these...
Which is so uncomfortable, I know it is.
- I had no idea that was about
to come out of your mouth, that's awesome.
- I go on these you
YouTube dumpster dives.
- Oh.
- Where I just watch compilation
videos of "The Voice".
- Oh.
- But I only wanna see
the ones that are chosen,
'cause it makes me too sad
to see the ones that are rejected.
- You should be there when it happens.
- Okay, see, I got a lot of questions,
I got a lot of questions.
But, my favorite thing is
when you guys turn around
and you have that reaction of who it is.
'Cause I love that you
only hear their voice.
- Absolutely.
- I have seen every season,
every compilation video.
The best is seeing the parents in
the back react when you guys turn around.
That is just immediate joy.
I just, I can't get enough of it.
- I love that.
- I love it, I love it,
I love it.
Any of those kind of competitions.
- Yeah.
- Videos, I love.
(crowd applauds)
- So your a music lover then?
- I love, I love music.
- Oh, we have something
in common actually.
- But you know what song, I'm,
oh, what?
- Patty Griffin.
- Yeah!
- Patty Griffin is the best.
- Do you guys know who Patty Griffin is?
- If you don't, you're welcome.
(laughing)
'Cause we just introduced you to
the most amazing singer, songwriter.
- Her voice, much like yours is--
- [Kelly] Not like mine.
- Yeah, much like yours,
is just completely pure.
That mountain song, which you covered,
which I saw on YouTube.
- Yeah, "Up in the Mountain".
I love you!
- Up to the mountain.
(laughing)
- And I also--
- I'm gonna have you on all
the time to sing my praises.
- But she just has an
organic quality to her songs.
And I've...
Now I'm turning into a real crazy person.
- I love this.
- Do you know, there was a YouTube
when you were doing a
performance, I can't,
I'm so excited I get to
tell you this face to face.
(Kelly laughs)
You were doing a performance in the UK
and you had a gold shimmery
dress on and a black belt
and there was a
- Oh was there a drumline?
- Marching band drumline
- I know, I know, yes.
- And you were singing "Mr. Know it All"
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And I have played that,
I'm all those views.
- That dress was so tight.
(audience applauds)